yeah I'm ready so hello everyone my name
is Alexander ah I'm partner and senior
consultant at a strategic consultancy
conics week we were based in Mannheim
probably some of you know I'm also like
quite active member and the Python
community so I'm program chair of this
year's Europe - euro sigh pie and the
pike on D in Python
I did a Castro arm which is happening in
October so and also we just found it by
data Frankfurt and Southwest so I like
to speak and talk about tech so this is
basically what we do as a company arm so
we're talking based on digital
transformation
I personally consult on data science
modern matters and provide trainings
it's the talk is more about like it's a
fun ride about the the big space of how
we could basically generate a text um
and one disclaimer this is probably part
one off the talk probably one of many
actually because it's more about a work
in progress than providing many
solutions um so if you want to produce a
lot of texts or like Generic or dramas
or ever leave now um you're not getting
this here so where does my inspiration
for all this come from it comes of
course from PI data from PI data London
June Cogan he's an artist he gave a
great keynote picasso's turnable about a
cell transfer and neural networks in art
so you can watch the video and also on
one point like we're trying to fix the
this is basically usually the slides are
supposed to be 1629 so but due to some
constraints here we have four to three
now so everything will be a little bit
compressed sorry for that I can't fix it
okay so this I thought this was awesome
because maybe my first curry actually
was in the music industry so and I came
within the music industry to programming
attacks so I can always like really
lay to anything with art and creation
and all the stuff and just like it to do
why later
I had the first business challenge to
solve because it was also in a space of
digital images but they were looks like
some requirements we had to move had
some older digital images like to size
to scale up to meet modern requirements
because for example in also in the music
industry you could have like a cover 60
600 by 600 it was like when iTunes
started now it's like three thousand two
or three thousand so and if you move
want to move any content with old
digital images you have to scale it out
and the regular scale up stuff is not
good enough so actually I explore the
space and came up into super resolution
and this work well I know usually the
gif should actually basically okay okay
so um this worked well and after a
proof-of-concept we had a GPU I said
okay to further this project let's get
an e GPU this is this new thing you
probably have heard about it's an
external box so basically we can have
like and you can put a nice and video
graphic card in into this box and plug
it
we have Thunderbolt to your macbook so
this was this is a really great because
it can have it have everything on your
Mac and work have like build up like a
little app and have all the
computational power we need phone number
numerical operations with a graphic card
without all the cloud hassle so this is
great so I had this box and basically it
was a little troublesome to install all
this just like some hints um although of
course Apple was it hates plug and play
and great and Sierra supports now or
whatever hi Sarah or whatever it's
called it now supports all externally
GPUs it's a lot of trouble to set up I
can totally recommend you eg Pui all if
you ever think about doing this and a
really lot of kudos to do these two guys
go left
because they build great installers and
instructions how to really make it work
because actually you can make it work
but some stuff actually matters you need
a very specific driver from Nvidia and
really the build number of Mac OS
matters so if you have a fresh install
or if you use the combo update so and
after um maybe some days and no more
picture okay okay so I got this to work
and said okay now I have this box at
hand and all the power so let's get this
going so the part of my journey actually
started on a long weekend where I had
some time all for myself and I said okay
let's do star transfer because I think
who knows style transfer ok style and
fur was in the media I'm so half now so
I explained a little bit um San Fran so
was actually pretty big in the media
also so basically the ideas you have one
picture like a painting by Van Gogh and
you can transfer it on an image for
example so you can have like a van Gogh
painting of Tubingen at night so this is
the picture on the top left is the
original picture and all the others are
basically a style being transferred from
a classic painting
oh wow great um I was really attracted
to that so I just like said let's move
into space all right I decided okay
let's go for this veronique comic let's
call in Germany in French it's Bellavia
and in English it's but I got a novel no
um it's it's a comic I like to read as a
kid and I really like the style I like
comics from France from the area and
there's these new comics for something
like this flash comic which I think
visually not that attractive so my first
question was am I ever
first I'll transfer question was can I
transfer the style from I know oh sorry
you know transfer the style from very
unique French comic to a modern marvel
comic so we see those you'll see the
left comic page in the style and on the
right side this new one and this is my
ever first-ever
star transfer edit and you see Wow
everybody everybody said wow great so
this was very motivating so I took these
styles I learned and applied them to
holiday pictures Wow cool applied them
to classic art I've had just
photographed in some Museum who and
built more styles on other comics and
you see like this really psychedelic
belonging week scene again applied to
even yeah multiple holiday pictures and
okay and I just experimented it it was
just like a really cool weekend for me
um you can apply to whole pages
I even tried with just like us out of
curiosity what will happen with a really
classic flash comic I mean these flash
comics are around since like then I am i
think the 40s so and I had these like
really blurry scans from the internet
you can hardly read it and I just
applied the style and you got a really
like a fresh copy of it so it actually
was really improving the images as well
this was quite nice and last but not
least I trained another picture and just
if you apply a white noise to it and
it's basically whoa you could mail this
to friends I've just visited Maura Tate
Modern in London and I liked this
picture and it also led to some
discussions where does the arts are and
stuff so yeah it was really great so um
so sum it up um I was really hooked like
oh this is like really great and what do
I have on what do we need to further
this because now the the idea is
building a ver so I got my local eg bu
lab I've got the ability or knowledge
how to scale it to the cloud since I was
just playing around on a wee parent
still reports the DLT and documentation
of all my experience purrs like little
more like baby steps yet so I had to fix
that and also I had to choose a
framework because you can use like
something like tensorflow or Cara's or
PI toge and actually I just make sure I
settle for PI taught because I just
thought it's research friendly for me it
was really a very easy to get into PI
torch as a Python Esther has a great
community and
support by a major company so I sort of
hope a torch also some lessons to learn
because I have any GPU and Mac so it's
not just like Conda install PI torch if
you want to have the GPU running so yeah
so it has to be compiled and also one
learning because usually I expect you
have like a major project like PI torch
they have a death a death branch they
also have like it a master branch no
basically they have only one master
branch and all the latest stuff is
always in there so if you want to
compile the newest version it might
break because PI torch is a very complex
project with many many dependencies on
other projects so finally I found out
some of the other dependencies broke the
compiler and so you had to basically
look for the right version in PI torch
to make it work so this is another
lesson learned so if I torch does not
compile just check out a different
branch usually you find someone in a
forum and a date when it works and
basically that's a good point
so yeah actually this is like a so so
now I like to the journey begins now how
I came up with the whole idea and you
can imagine like after a transfer and
everything basically felt like this wow
cool let's go for it
NLP like AI on deep deep neural Nets can
basically solve everything because it
were so grateful style transfer anyway
so the the thing was I was super
thrilled thrilled this is basically how
you end up if you spend the evening with
in Oslo from potato London you end up
exploring hotels building sites and ok
so I thought ok that's it's so great why
not even like synthesize this and who's
who's from Germany here who knows this
ok sir so I said ok this is like a
really big mission now so what are like
the eath these three question marks
actually it's a live target seishun
nobody knows why the target session is
written drive target session Ferguson
Ferguson but it's and actually an
American juvenile detective book series
which was adapted in German
and is it's there are books it started
actually in 80 60s and it's released
since the late seventies in Germany and
they're like to more than 200 books and
taped radio dramas there and it it's
very popular it's basically something I
grew up with so this was of course
really um motivating oh why can i
synthesize something I grew up with and
full disclaimer I still have the latest
episode because it's still running so
what is apart from the the archetypes
and they account for about 80% of the
the whole Hirschfeld market in Germany
that's sad
so it's big so what's the Hearst feel
it's a taped radio drama so now we're
like starting in the area of
pre-internet even like pre television
there was a radio drama so it was like a
drama with multiple actors speaking with
each other the most famous one you
probably know is awesome Welles in the
War of the Worlds world where he
basically made like a radio drama sound
like a life report about aliens invading
Earth and people were actually calling
the police and panic yeah it's like it's
all like and he was like ok it was like
he's he's quite a genius he was like and
I think his mid 20s or so so it's a
taped radio drama I think this is a
strange translation that's the closest
one we can get it's an art from its of
its own it features voice recordings
dialogues interaction between characters
cuts noises ambient sounds and also
music and makes us so basically it's
like a film without picture so this is
how basically um stuff looks like so me
my young younger Alex have like it this
this cassette here the target session
and fluster Mumia which is like the
whispering mummy um so we have these the
cassette and it sounds like just to give
you like a little impression the text
does not match the displayed the the
sound does not match that the words here
it's just like to see here Fellini Sara
he worked as many so many years or four
years of
devoted clownish spinner he can anything
right thousand yeah at the Mumia this is
how basically the outward looks like so
if you go to store online you will find
these online so basically to synthesize
a her spiel they're four ingredients
needed I need a story or a plot so
actually what's happening and he
dialogues so dynamic human speech it's
not just like and constant sequence of
words like in a audiobook we need a
cover like a picture and we need like
really spoken word with the star
transfer up like so we need to recognize
a returning characters because there are
three investigators Peter no just those
Peter Bob and as all they are in every
episode of course and there's some other
returning characters there so start with
the realization what do we need I need
some transcripts I need some text to
learn from and I already have the
recordings in my private collection on a
technology stack we have the local GPU
on can move scale to the cloud if you
need it in this case I use the Google
cloud I have pi toge in the latest
version Jupiter lab - 36 and of course
what various other libraries I want to
approach each of these ingredients was
like give the same process data
acquisition data cleaning research paper
and a working solution reproduce this
working solution very Fri it's really
working then move on and apply it and
adapt it for my or the use case we were
looking up and later on if possible
maximize the quality and while i doing
what's doing all this research there's
one thing I really have to mention with
this run related to stalk I saw a lot of
Python to the Python version who knows
like who knows this who knows that
Python is going to die in the year - -
is no longer being
Porter so you must not use - two seven
for any new project because this is the
final deadline and happy has been
already extended so and you see it I saw
like on a very hot latest Facebook
library on github - - seven and then
from sometimes also if I look at code
you find there like more from a
programmers perspective you see okay and
it's also like no hope there's no Python
3/8 it's a sceeto from Rossum the
beneficial dictator for life so there
won't be another approachment this is
really the end this is serious
another thing is code quality and
readability actually in the in libraries
found out there there are keywords used
for variable names so and there's a lot
of closures going on and this is basic
probably related to each opt notebook
and I think it makes the code really
often not really understandable from
from outsiders who has not read this
code so import is a keyword probably
it's also like the explenation people
use to seven because three won't compile
it's a syntax error then yeah okay this
is just like a side note because like
the Python free thing is an important
message go back let's go back to our
story here um so let's look at the text
we need to fabricate the text to be
spoken by a character so what's the
process so actually I was really lucky I
found fan-made transcripts so my first
idea was to use Google speech or any
like speech API but a fan-made fan made
PDFs I read in the regulations if a fan
picks up the project to do this
transcript he has like 12 month time so
and I reviewed some of them and the
quality seemed to be good so but
downside they were like PDFs they
included extra instructions like noises
background noises so you hear like
clapping slapping and stuff like that or
it's written down in a text as well so I
pre-process the text with text tracks
and I was able to basically identify
each and every dialogue there against a
character the character names I got from
another fan page which features an index
of all the characters ever
occurred so in turtle we just have a
German language corpus with 1.5 million
words and 56 thousand words
unique words yes so and of course the
first thing to jump to the one the the
source we inspire this is so easy to
create text with recurrent neural
networks this was from Andy Kappa fees
block who knows this blog post okay okay
in this blog post andy karate he was
doing his PhD he's not a data chief data
scientist of Tesla describes recurrent
neural networks and how you can use them
basically to generate texts and one of
his examples is to generate Shakespeare
sonnets so something like like this so
and this looks very convincing to me um
I'm not a native English speaker looks
looks convincing and so basically it's
said wow it's already proven so all
basically just reproduce this example
and very Fri I had and I did was able to
reproduce something which looked equally
Shakespeare II to me as like this and
now let's try it with the German coppers
I had straight so I was I couldn't wait
basically to push the button and this is
basically what came out this is a result
who's a native German speaker yeah and
who's a non native German suppose not a
non native German speaker or who would
totally accept this as medieval German
yeah you see people are laughing um it
actually results I earn and when we use
its character based so why user are and
with character based iron and of course
it uses less space so because the
matrixes are way smaller because I think
in total I work with like forty
characters here so of course this is way
less than having a space of more than
fifty thousand words to cover so yeah
this was really nice and you can also
like you chat uses like in group chats
with your friends and this is what you
will get back yeah yeah so it's like so
that just like who knows no Vong is like
the youth language basically yeah it was
they call the youth language so okay so
this was alright it was actually very
interesting and amusing but it's not
really like the goal that's so not there
yet so I tried vert based yeah which is
not as amusing just like a little bit
because I still haven't figured out
where actually the word slum green and
came from it's so ok but it actually
it's amusing but it's not really I can
produce something with this so okay I
tried something else of course there's
still a lot of space to explore to go
deeper here and and and and because this
is just like a simple RN and we don't
even use any attention here so there's
still some space but the problem is
maybe also like the data set is too
small and then transfer learnings needed
required I also thought about okay can
maybe a chatbot help what I'm looking
for dialogues why not create dialogues
with chat box and I just did like more
like a smoke test here and because I
read about the Captain Picard bot and
basically this is built on tenza for and
uses all the Star Trek next generation
dialogues and basically you can have
great your own basically like the author
claims you can create a new episode and
play a character here and I just tried
and it was was also not really driving
into this direction at least from this
work actually it was quite annoying
because I got little notes in Twitter
notifications for a day okay so let's
move on so like from the checks hmm not
so but what about the speech because we
also we want to produce an HP so we also
need fabricate spoken language and not
only spoken language it should also
sound like one of the characters so how
can we do this so I will I found the l
LJ speech data set in English it's or
freely it's open openly available and I
came across
turkleton true um so and this paper here
so it's basically synthesizing a natural
language we have rave net and using mail
specter cramps to synthesize what's the
Mel's back to cram because actually able
submitters is first time I ever heard
about Mel spectrograms Mara spectrogram
is something it's an acoustic time
frequency representation of sound so if
I say a or a word you can have like a
spectrogram like here so catch all the
frequency and different sounds and have
reduced representation like here and
here you see on top you see the model
actually which is used below you see an
input and an output
Mel spectrogram on a very right side you
see on this it's a comparison how well
the two on the Left match so okay so a
little bit more about the data side use
the LJ speech data set um it's in
English it contains 30,000 clips of a
single speaker reading stuff from seven
non-fictional books so we have like 24
hours of audio that's okay
let's try can we produce something so
and I started to train this network and
we train on a single GPU it's like a GTX
1080 here and after 10 basically that
was it we just have a text corpus and
the audio files belonging
to the line in the text file we attach
so basically just a text
throw some audio edit and have the
network learn and what can we get out of
it so let's see this is like after like
ten hours of training is they just some
rhythm actually I think this could be
used for cool electronic music stop for
ten hours but after 14 hours so we see
our little baby starts to walk actually
not the five days of training once upon
a time there was a little mermaid named
sire who lived with her stepmother under
the seed he didn't get to go out of the
sea like any other of the nine days of
training okay sorry for that okay some
things ring no other the last after nine
days it's not degrading again actually
the nice thing was actually low or let
me let me show you I can find it very
quick I'll just play it from here once
upon a time there was a little mermaid
named
Styron who lived with her stepmother
under the sea she didn't get to go out
of the sea like any other so you see
already like the the neural network
like really picked up on siren and make
pauses so actually I thought this was
quite amazing because there was not much
basically to do of course this is not
something you can sell all but on the
other hand it is something not uncommon
of course like some something like a
serial actor has a better pronation and
everything but this is just like
something trained on commodity hardware
in a week and without like probably tens
of like tens of millions of probably
hundreds of millions of money so this is
really simple I have to move to the next
slide so okay yeah so this is basically
this is the key message is papery not
the the best voice ever but you see that
the potential here ya know looking for
it right slide and don't want to go back
to the audio slide okay so this is like
this is the I think how accessible
everything basically is and this was a
nice proper data set actually a try I
said I was like hey the networks working
great let's do this for German and then
I had to do a lot of research and
finally I only found one German corpus
which was accessible and I just threw
that the network and to find out it's
not working at all so this is actually a
big issue I discovered you have all this
material out there it's all in English
English language wise I would argue is
simpler than German and so we lacked
material we have a more complicated
language to manage it's really hard to
do something and to work on the data
quality so next because I don't really
need this in Germany Germany because I
can still get something as a basis from
some speech output from probably
something like zero an API so what about
the voice style transfer who has heard
about voice style transfer okay boy
style transfers actually you learn how
somebody sounds
yeah and transfer it on and some other
spoken audio so basically there are
there's one paper out it says I think
else on the next page I'll show you
so basically um I started working on the
voice tile transfer and I had like these
two radio dramas at hand in my private
collection anyway so the task was how
can I separate the dialogues for each
character because I don't want the
mixture of all characters involved
everyone they used to Ziona separated
and this so make a long story sport I
use this transcription via the Google
Cloud a speech API because it gives me
back and index and word and time index
funny finding was actually we use
recordings which are quite well-armed
and the Google speech API actually
wasn't working as well actually I
expected of a perfect almost perfect
transcription but the consumption really
lacked and it had really some bad
language for something made for children
actually in there so yeah but
nonetheless um I could work around it I
had the texts from from the the fan fan
scripts I had the stuff from the Google
Cloud API and basically solved the way
to match the two together to see where I
can automatic cuts was actually to use
engrams so I used one two three engrams
to see to search for dialogue start
dialogue and and then basically and do
an estimate where where to cut so this
worked well
still but it's still in the process
because I have nothing to transfer on
yet because the data set was not is not
finished here yet um so next step is
solve the data problem gets something
working on in German for speech improve
the other data set for the dialogues and
this is you see here's the the example
for the star transfer for speech um yeah
so basically there's some nice examples
up there on on Soundcloud like Kate
Winslet really an audiobook though five
minutes ok of speed up though this is
dialogues and interaction between people
and a tie
being of a radio drama is not just
another challenge than having somebody
reading an audiobook and probably the
same speed all the time so plot this is
still in the making because the research
here how a plot basically works goes way
back so I skip this part so at last what
can I do with the artwork because
basically this is my entry drug so can i
fabricate new artwork meeting the style
of the series so we use an conversion
neural net for that so this is from the
original paper here yes so you see how
the network's proceeds and the input
images and the style trained so I built
a data set to test how the style was
working this is just like the data that
the data set of different pictures from
different styles to apply the styles on
and also another lesson learned is there
are limits also interactive in
extracting style images to a model so
sometimes you see if you read online its
cherry-picking everybody's just
presenting the stuff that really works
well something like this I mean have
this tunnel view and I have this and all
the image which most of the time it
really works well on any style and then
for example I have this this is one of
the episodes
panicum Park and I try to learn the
style from this picture and apply to the
tunnel view which always works amazing
anybody get something but it's not
really mm-hm okay do we need for that
but most of the times
nobody will show this and also like if
you look at get helps and gets and
repositories you always see like the
same image it's reproduce they don't
even add new our own material there so
it's yeah also like there's limits
applying style models to images so for
example this this is a picture I totally
expected super suitable for style
transfer and then you see some sample
stars transferred on the image a nice
way
yeah that's just throwing a little Carol
there but it's not not really picking
anything up so yeah so and also nobody
will show you the stuff that doesn't
work so this is another works always
tiger here you see some amazing star
transfers really nice but nobody shows
you this only me
so can I produce the cover which looks
like this and full disclaimer I already
showed you in the my very beginning when
I showed this earlier I already
presented three fakes already so you can
guess which ones are fakes
um I think we are out of time to make a
little yeah yeah so actually for your
fakes already and I think they're not
not very obvious I did some tests of
people here so that's promising I can I
just reveal them
so the covers actually look different so
actually I think okay this went quite
far reproducing like an art style of a
series for for further use um of course
future steps you see like the the images
from the covers they have reduced their
own sometimes have only three colors or
so so of course something to look to
even improve it would be like multi star
transfer also like played around with
like chaining star transfer so applying
a style and applying another star on a
flying dog which works quite well as
well and also like there to look more
into how can I do a pre selection of
stuff that works well together
thank you so to sum it up basically I
would say don't get crazy about the
stuff you can read out there there's
some amazing stuff out there on the on
the on these topics I love that we have
these open access to all the material
datasets code explanation papers but you
still have to think it's it's research
papers it's really fresh from academia
so give it some time to settle in for
production so I plan to do this like to
give
but if anybody wants to hear about this
I'm happy to give an update on further
proceedings and maybe in a year or so
because I think I still enjoy a lot each
of these topics further then just one
last quick announcement so if you're
ever like in Mannheim or Sutras Germany
there are two new meetups there so if
you want to speak and give us a visit
we are very hospitable and nice people
to hang out with so just ping me also
there's the conference high data high
school and PyCon de at the set car I'm
in Kailua it's the center of media out
in Cairo we ran the conference there
last year
already it's end of October and yeah
thank you
[Applause]
thanks very much Alex for a very
entertaining talk are there any
questions in the audience
Thanks your talk is very interesting
yeah I have two questions here the first
question is how many epochs that use for
style transfer and your text generation
approximately epochs okay actually not
too many actually the style was picked
up very quickly and I did not see much
improvement and so probably you can get
something to check the style after like
a hundred epochs is is it applied as
well for the text generation the text is
I think harder to judge on because I
mean an image you have more flexibility
on a text we can basically immediately
say go bad or hopefully at least funny
but a picture we have made more
flexibility in this space
so I can present you like a picture in
the multiple versions and you probably
say all of them nah nice but if
something in text and this is I the real
challenge in a natural language
processing you will see okay this is
word is off and disorder that the
problem is way harder to solve there do
you mean that impacts generation is it
hard to judge the result quote no the
opposite actually in text that's very
simple to judge good bad right sentence
wrong sentence on an image there's more
freedom likes like a painting it's a
good painting a good photograph or not
it's the eye of the the guy who looks at
it as we say in Germany so you recommend
hundred people I'm sorry now you put
this discussion maybe align with some
some other people want to ask some more
questions I have one last question quick
one okay sorry just a quick one you have
shown this German text generation and in
your view what could be improved maybe
some other ways other than finding the
better corpus I don't hear it constantly
you have shown this German tax
generation yeah
and I just want to know if you have any
other idea to improve the tax evasion
other than finding better improving the
data basically it's very problem always
like improving the data um that's one of
all the other key learnings usually the
data quality is the first thing to solve
in the beginning there are any more
questions somewhere do you have another
question I have one more question so
this was quite a quite an exciting
journey what's what's kind of the the
end goal of that project or restoring
ankle or where are you wandering off
next yeah actually the next thing is
definitely to look into more into how to
improve dialogues and texts that's
that's where I want to head next and I
have to hire more working students so I
have people to cut the audio and stuff
so yeah actually like the dialogues and
discussions from the dialogues because
also like here still is the question I
have the dialogues I have probably have
some hours of just as units talking but
is this enough and sufficient data for
style transfer also like because the
dialogues can be very different he can
be like super excited down whispering
and it's not like as in the examples I
have mentioned earlier the audio books
where somebody's just like reading a
book and of course with some expression
but not like the excitement of
interaction between humans and yeah that
sounds great looking forward to to next
year then thank you any any last
question we have time for one last
question maybe if not please thank the
speaker again thank you very much
[Applause]